وصلت قبل قليل الشاحنات التي تحمل
المساعدات القطريه وصلت الى الجانب السوري
من معبر باب الهوى هذه الشاحنات عباره عن
سبع شاحنات سوف تدخل بعد قليل الاراضي
السوريه وبحسب
المتطوعين في الهلال الاحمر القطري فان
هذه
المساعدات سوف توزع الى المنكوبين
والمتضررين فورا بمعنى انها لن تستقر في
مخازن هي سوف تنتقل مباشره الى المتضررين
وكذلك المنكوبين بسبب الزلزال المساعدات
الموجوده من اهل القطر من صندوق قطر
للتنميه خلال الاحمر وقطر الخيريه وهي
مساعدات تخدم المضررين خلال فتره الاجواء
اليوم بارده وممطره كذلك تهددت منازلهم
باذن الله راح نتحرك من هاي العطور على
مواقع اللي حددت من قبل الجهات المختصه
المحليه وين راح يكون فيها مخيمات او
توزيعات مخصصه للسكان المحليين في داخل
السوري ندعم بالخيام والالتزامات الاوليه
اللي يستخدمها كل شخص يحتاج مثل هذه
الامور كذلك المسيره الطبيه اليوم راح
نكون في زياره على بعض المستشفيات الطبيه
ونطلع الاحتياجاتهم اللي راح ان شاء الله
في الايام القادمه خلال الحمله
طبعا
وبالنسبه للمساعدات الهلال الاحمر القطري
كانت وصلت يوم امس ودخلت الى الجانب
السوري من ايضا من معبر باب الهوى وبحسب
المتطوعين في الهلال الاحمر القطري فان
الوفد القطري الذي دخل كان معه اطباء من
عده اختصاصات
مباشره هؤلاء الاطباء عمليه اجراء عمليات
جراحيه